pesy he's connected somehow he comes on
SNL he had dude he had his he he was
dressed like straight out a good Fellas
he said are you Italian I said no I'm
not Italian and he said then where do
you get off using words like guinea W
and on television I said wow I got
you know I got an Italian guy to help me
write this thing he goes um but here's
the deal no one gives a about riters
you're the performer you're the one that
whose mouth com out of like oh my God
I'm going to have to pay Joe pesi 10 15%
of my money the rest of my life and I it
finally ended with me basically saying
listen I'm a fan I never meant to insult
you this was I I I I just this all just
happen we'll never do I'm never doing
this again never ever doing this again
and he turned around I was like who I'm
busting your balls really all my life he
wasn't busting you don't think he was